about two weeks ago on twitter one of
the people who i follow issued a very
interesting challenge which had to do
with documents and with the wombo ai art
generator
and the suggestion was that we should
take our theses and dissertations titles
whether at the phd or masters or
bachelor's level
and input those as prompts to see what
kind of imagery
wombo would come up with so i decided to
do that
with i actually have all three a
bachelor's
honors thesis a master's thesis and a
phd dissertation the phd dissertation
title was a little bit too long to use
as a prompt but my bachelor's worked
just fine and it's
a document that i no longer have i'm
sure it's stored somewhere at lakeland
university and it was called
truth self-referential isomorphic
statement groups
and you might say well what the hell is
that about well so
i was very much into the intersections
between philosophy and mathematics and
logic
at the time
and you know the notion of using
mathematics to represent things was you
know kind of a cool idea i was playing
around with and when you've got
isomorphisms things are are connected
with each other in interesting ways
where there's a mapping function going
on
and truth self-referential means that
you have a statement that either refers
to its own truth or is part of a set of
statements that are all connected
together that in some way refer to each
other's truth so the liars paradox is a
prime example as a matter of fact played
an important role in that the liar's
paradox is very simple you can do it in
in several different ways one is for me
to say i am lying to you right now right
if it's true then i'm lying to you so
then it's false but if it's false then
it means i'm not lying to you so i'm
telling the truth you see where this is
going and so i was playing around with a
lot of these sorts of things and i you
know i don't need to go through what the
thesis was about instead i'm much more
interested in
what this was about so isomorphic truth
suffer self-referential statement groups
right a nice title
what does wombo generate you see some of
the images there behind me and we're
going to look at
all of the images that it generated
in just a bit people get very
preoccupied i'll say is the last thing
about is this art or not who's the
artist and i don't really care about
that sort of stuff frankly myself
that's issues for other people who are
much more concerned about that i'm
really interested in what kind
of cool imagery does this generate so
i'm going to take you on a little trip
through what this
title isomorphic truth self referential
statement groups
provides us with and let's see what it
looks like
here is the first image that was
generated using that prompt from my
bachelor's honors thesis and i like this
one quite a bit it looks almost like a
cloud city
but when we start looking at it from
going from the top to the bottom we see
some cool and interesting features first
of all there's a person in the landscape
at the top and then as we scroll down we
see something like houses and buildings
stacked on top of each other and it goes
all the way down to a base it's not just
hanging there in the clouds
when we turn to the next one again we
see very architectural features to this
but now there's a clear explicit
addition
of human beings one of the artistic
themes that is going to run through
quite a few of these so if we begin at
the top we see
this beautiful you know city sort of
built up out of other bits and pieces
hanging up in the sky and then we scroll
our way down
and we see human-like figures none of
them are particularly great
people constructions and some of them
are a bit grotesque but you can identify
them as people and they're there in the
middle of the city perhaps looking up at
it if we look at them very closely you
can see that you know what we've got
here
does look like it has faces in some
places or hands but it's rather
grotesque and some of them blend in a
bit at points with the city itself
now in the next one we have a very
different kind of motif
one that just has
patterns that are renderland of writing
perhaps or some sort of script
and where they're all bunched up on top
of each other if we
scroll down through this we see that
there's no writing anywhere in it but
there's writing like things and some of
them are nested inside of each other
very colorful very cool i think
this is another one that's quite similar
but it's not quite so colorful it's much
more
muted and if we look at this one we'll
go from the bottom to the top same sort
of deal we're not seeing an actual
script we're seeing something that it
that imitates it or apes it and maybe
could be interpreted as if we zoom in
and we look
at this
non-writing
this interesting calligraphy or
cuneiform or pictograms there's no
actual
information there is there there's only
the hint of it
going on again
we managed to combine both of these
themes in this one which is actually my
favorite of all of the ones generated
for isomorphic truth self-referential
statement groups and if we
zoom in on it once again this luminous
beautiful semi-writing is not quite
writing as such but it's worth checking
out and then we have the people down
here it seems to be that the theme is
putting together a number of robed
people who maybe are conferring about
these matters and we can like scroll
from them up into this writing and it's
almost as if it's
you know a monolith hanging over them
that they're interpreting of course
that's very subjective on my part
here we have something that almost looks
more like a library at first and from
the outset we're looking at it and it
looks like there's humanoid figures
involved with maybe books or
writing behind them and then you know a
basis of a book but if we start at the
top and we work our way downward
maybe this isn't actually human beings
maybe this is just garments or even like
skin suits that have been thrown
together
as we go down further we get something
that could be a human being
seeded we also get something that looks
suspiciously like a chicken
and then we have this bottom part which
almost looks like a book itself turned
on its side
then we get a really trippy one and this
is another one that i particularly like
where we combine the humanoid figure
with the
potential writing
if we start at the top we have this you
know really trippy
kind of background that is is less
linear more circular now and we go down
to these figures who now look more
owl-like than human
perhaps or avian at least all the way
down to
the
things that they are surrounded by or
surrounding
and those are those are kind of cool if
we zoom in on it we can see like here's
a
figure with that
what do we want to call it like wall of
of writing or symbols
so that that's an interesting one here's
another really interesting one um this
one it's more like a composite of a
giant figure with a head whose head is
composed of many other things it's it is
i think the steampunk one and there's a
lot of other stuff going on in this one
if we begin at the bottom we see
something that could be a little ship
perhaps uh some some mountains and it
leads upward into the figure who is
composed of all sorts of deformities and
monstrosities
tied together uh if we look at it more
closely there's faces within it as well
and then it fades off into the
background
here's one as well that also has a large
figure and
something that looks like a face if we
begin at the bottom we have what appear
to be more architectural features and
again massive shoulders leading up into
something that's clearly a
face there's eyes and a nose to it and
then the
helmet or headdress or hair is composed
of all sorts of other stuff as well this
is a really interesting one and i
believe this was the pastel
here we have just a single figure or
what appears to be a figure
because
well there's two things to say so we'll
come back to the figure in a moment look
at the ground the ground is more
circular or ovaloid
but it also does have that same
appearance of like conveying
information or script but now it's the
land itself now if we zoom in on the
figure and we get closer and closer
it looks on the one hand less and less
like a human being
more and more as if it's just part of
the landscape and we get to see that
the landscape itself
does look quite a bit different than
some of the other ones that we've seen
here's the last one this is another
favorite of mine in part because of the
celestial imagery of it it's quite
beautiful
and if we start at the bottom we have
some human figures we have some you know
some
some painterly stuff that i myself would
love to be able to do we go up into
through this this curve and we have a
number of other seemingly humanoid
figures in various stances and then we
have the
luminous
heavens themselves again very brushworky
quite
beautiful so those are the ones that are
generated by
using this prompt that derives from the
title of my senior thesis
isomorphic truth self referential
statement groups and we'll do more of
these in the future with my master's
thesis and my dissertation and see what
comes out of those
you